bah moi je vous dise où
il veut des sous alors que tu expliques
ça au death ou changent de sienne
changent d'âne change de producteurs
c'est beau ça oula c'est magnifique
c'est keith a lancé isaac une petite
mare laquelle je connais très bien c'est
beau ce qu'il faudrait c'est très bien
ce qu'ils font
on dirait victor le public à la ferme ta
gueule
mais six mois alors qu'est ce tu veux la
question c'est trop loin non moi
j'arrive
sur le cas l'année prochaine tu vas
paraît demandé c'est bon mais là il m'a
alors moi j'aimerais bien que vous
acceptez que je reste dans tpm p bravo
je le devrais voilà je leur donne donc
rester dans tpm pays restait dans tpm t
à un salaire identique à ce
qu'il n'y aura pas d'augmentation balle
diminuait la vallasse émission là sachez
que l'émission sera vendu au même prix
et l'internation l'imputent à gueule
en apprenant jamais des mots qui toi
jamais jamais jamais jamais
et bah
oui et j'aimerais bien avoir un rendez
vous à moi un rendez vous voilà
notamment d'avoir des rendez vous sur
[Applaudissements]
enfin j'ai donc allée des landais ont
déjà fait des captures de requins mais
passagers de se tenir une émission à moi
quoi tu va être compliqué je vois ce que
je peux faire mais moi aussi non non
les mecs arrêtez les mecs vous voyez
bien qu'il ya très peu d'émissions la
weed pour ça voilà les mecs
ça va m'aider fait un truc un peu sympa
qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] ça me dit
tu crois vraiment que je mette de
l'hôtel melia lodyans fait de romagnat
les animaux qui cartonne oui c'était
s'est bien battu rien tu crois qu'il est
maître bernard montiel qui a coûté une
tonne et celle qui va pas boyer connard
[Rires]
moi ce que j'en à vous de dimanche soir
quoi orient qu'est-ce que j'en appelle
aux assedic cimade a connu dimanche à
lundi mais tu sais combien vous coûte
les films ça s'emballe collaborait oui
la mère d'anne et ça cartonne larissa
clôture coûte une tonne et demie ce que
tu me fais comme omnium
sa peinture est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les maires dégâts sur le
dc-8 ne s'est jamais aussi bien portée
ajout du g8 ne s'est jamais aussi bien
portée donc forcément on va pas changer
grand chose face à chelsea si on arrive
on est en train de voilà de réfléchi
vitesse de croisière qua non ça c'est
bien alors voilà quelques petits
aménagements bien entendu ok les films
des trucs voilà mais met une émission le
dimanche après-midi la programmer revenu
médian sachez qu'il ya animaux adoptés
qui cartonne oui c'est très belle à
cette marche très fort donc je vais pas
mettre de l'argent plus pour voir des
têtes de cons
vous pensez à qui
vous pas vous mais tout le monde voilà
qui vont nous coûter une tonne qui vont
me rapporter la 0 alors moi je vais me
demander un truc qui va déplaire et toi
c'est fini toi
t'es peut pas passer ça y est elle est
là il est passé l'a jamais surpris
l'année prochaine ce qui m'étonnerait
oui le 6 à 7 tous les quinze jours
j'aimerais un alternance avec eux rigolo
la
moitié des rigolos oui parce qu'il a
plein d'émissions maintenant alors je
vais regarder je vais regarder ça je
peux regarder un peu regardez moi
je vais te dire moi ça ne me fait 50%
mais tout laisse prévoir de quoi
augmenter sur
moi c'est très simple oui si tu me fais
50 % moins cher que qahtani c'est pas du
tout les deux semaines que j'ai rarement
chez les jeunes explique comme tu vas
tomber le salaire je te fais 50 % dans
les pij en fait comme tu vas travailler
plus du ring c'est travailler plus pour
gagner moins
[Rires]
j'ai un truc et m'a dit qu'est ce que je
suis en train de te dire quoi il se
prête moins pays puisque tu vas plus on
faire
mais quel intérêt pour moi je veux dire
une autre phrase moi j'ai pas envie de
passer à la télé ça bien 38 ans que je
viens de 25% de bhopal be 200 pour cent
de rien assez beau assez
bien
vous me doubler le salaire et comme
c'est gentil
pour vous mais je vous mets 5 ans vous
me dit bernard je t'adore était
merveilleux ce qui est vrai bon
j'ai dit ok à 5,40 coûte que je suis en
train de perdre la tête mais j'ai trop
peu dans les airs il doublait pourquoi
il faut est ce que tu vas faire plus
d'émissions
dites moi vous dire sur moi
fait qu'une part le monde tu as fait
qu'une souris qui ne sont même pas mal à
les imaginer si je te paye - oui mais je
te fait faire les quatre semaines par
mois tu vas gagner plus que 6 fois par
semaine c'est bien alors
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
maintenant je vais faire un calcul
simple du p53 sens oui la fois sans ça
fait 4 cents ouais mais si moi je te
fais 20 x 50 ça fait mille
était gagnant ouais mais je rappelle ce
soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux réduire ton salaire de 50 % tu
gagneras plus je gagnerai plus à innover
me serais content ça c'est win win voilà
bah c'est lourd ça court benji bon signe
non comment ça tu as peur que je
t'embrouille oui
alors mais je veux dire le calcul il est
tout simple un est tout simplement je te
leur fait à ces machines ont tu prend
sens pour une émission là tu fais qu'une
semaine donc tu fais 4 x 100 ce qui te
fait 400 par mois là je te mets à 50
sauf que tu fais 20 émissions 20 voix
50000 c'est à dire que tu fais plus que
doubler son salaire j'ai bien compris
c'est assez mais cette intéressante
s'est alors avancé des causses yable si
la gauche a ben voilà sociale voyez
qu'on avance vous fait mal an leur mari
lors à quoi les mémés n'aura mais
t'inquiète pas lui est inquiète pas je
vais m'occuper de lui après
faisons point par point montiel un peu
ce faire ça peut se faire allez je note
montiel bien parti
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
castel adore mon chéri est alors tiens
justement castaldi pour moi celui qui
est à l'honneur ce week-end c'était pas
qu'il y ait même pas pu
m'expliquer vendredi benjamin castadi a
présenté tpe week-end plus de 1 million
carton et en plus devant doni benjamin
exceptionnellement à limiter pnpp paul
et là aussi succès que se passe-t-il au
tour de benjamin gates
s'est même offert le luxe de faire des
records alors face c'est vrai ce succès
cette hype autour de castaldi à la
direction de ses huit après décision
forte pour booster les audiences de la
chaîne les faire animer tout par
benjamin castaldi à toutes les émissions
de la grille a commencé par les animaux
de la 8 qui
deviendront les animaux de cast a
regardé regarder les animes auteurs
[Applaudissements]
blue
boys camarades babeurre du [ __ ]
remy emma ah oui
elle me dit au lieu de me ramener en
ville où j'avais je logeais chez un
copain la meuse est en bas un cours
d'eau c'est toujours d'en bas donc tu
descends et tu finiras par trouver ton
appartement c'est un peu aussi
[Applaudissements]
cataldi affaire arrive arrive à faire
des audiences alors qu'on ne comprend
rien ce qui c'est vrai c'est quand même
une prouesse non mais je vous dis c'est
une épée pour vous les points tu vas tu
n'aimes si on s'amusait le maqâm du pop
art hogan en amis les animaux de castin
regardez regardez
regardez regardez on l'est on a mis dans
casta midi à la place de william
regarder voilà ce que je préfère c'est
jim casta c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai dit celle-là n'est pas truqué
les gars drôle alors
que tu passes plus à 59,25
les 25 points vince a tué 500 que gagne
toujours plus une
voix comme quoi tient qu'à cela dit
qu'est ce que tu voudrais écouter bois
la même saison que c'était les genevois
travers ben non ça sera pas possible
sans pas tout faire on peut pas tout
faire à un moment il va y avoir des
choix à faire en plus je dois reprendre
le vendredi n'y va ça je pensais que
c'était ave au sénat mais tu pourrais en
faire encore là avant la fin de la
saison peut très bien fait en train de
voir sachez que si je ne fais pas le
vendredi joue et je vous dis castagné
celui ci aussi parce que benjamin
castaldi est très endetté
je le dis non mais c'est vrai et à
chaque fois qu'il fait le vendredi ça
lui permet face à elle le sauve un pays
soufflant il souffle un peu ils dorment
y est dense et voilà que sur lequel j'ai
fait une semaine incroyable c'est vrai
j'étais très bon temps incertain contre
vous avez pu rembourser des choses
belles écoles de chaque mois d'accord
tout soit journée % consacrés à la fin
oui ouais commencent à sortir la tête de
l'eau ou alors il ya encore un peu d'eau
mais berné comme on écope convaincant
dans combien d'années non non on va on
va trouver des accords j'espère aller 2
en faisant de son camp mais tout ça
c'est long quand je dis moi je touche du
bois j'espère que vous serez toujours là
sont debout et donc je ne vous lâche pas
donc la médaille la même c'est donc ça
naît ça me va bien d'accord vous avez
fait une belle saison dieu bénisse le
comte ory je
vais très très bon soir béatrice bon ça
sert à vous alors vous venez de plus en
plus un écoutez moi si j'avais la chance
de revenir l'année prochaine déjà je
parlerai pas l'argent parce que la
dernière fois que j'y sois bon venu
c'est bon
c'est bon mais c'est bon ça
c'est l'américaine
est est-ce qu'on peut transformer des
jours volant parce qu'on a inventé un
concept pour moi qui s'apprête à dire à
jean paulhan dans la semaine et le
vendredi à arrêter vous voler tout le
temps volé dans la voix qui était pas on
va voir ça hein mais ça s'annonce bien
pour vous
bea ça va c'est tout ce qu'on voulait
écoutez si en plus on pouvait mettre des
snacks dans les loges un peu comme dans
comme dans la rue
même si m on n'en met pas pour ne pas
avoir trop de nuisibles
oui qu'est-ce qu'il veut lui a pas dit
venu si jamais il vous prenait l'envié
de baisser pour revenir ce qui serait la
très sympathique de votre part ouais
j'aurais une revendication ckoi et de
demande ou là là où la revendication que
je ne veut plus discuter avec vous vous
me donner des rendez-vous tout le temps
à boulogne à neuilly dans le sud de la
france dont paris tous les thèmes avec
jamais las vegas le cul je pars pas en
vacances ou à 100 tout l'été je ne veut
plus discuter avec vous je demande à
discuter avec lionel stade le directeur
général d'abord il est là et ensuite il
est plus malléable que vous olala c'est
une forme de mépris
c'est une forme de mépris est-ce que la
requête est acceptée ou non c'est mal je
pense que tu es mal
tu as une augmentation j'ai pas dit ça
mais est ce que oui ou non tu fais une
augmentation je n'ai pas encore décidé
ce que
je t'ai dis là la réponse ni alors non
je peux rien vous dire tout de suite
moins qu'ils aient pas non mais moi je
préfère maintenant il y aura tentation
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation pour
personne personne personne perçoit
d'acception pourquoi je fais ça dans la
formation c'est pas du tout
pourquoi parce que je déteste les
disparités
s'est rencontré et je déteste que
l''indice moi j'ai une augmentation
palma et à rien
j'ai des problèmes aussi que je préfère
des rayons d'avoir quatre personnes mais
pourquoi tout le monde est au même
niveau aujourd'hui si vous voyez
maintenant alors je vous dire nous c'est
une question de d'ancienneté vous vous
êtes ancien pas dans la vie parce que
sinon tu as dit m
[Applaudissements]
daniel yves outre être extrêmement cher
dans
l'émission c'est une question de
d'ancienneté dans l'émulsion voilà et
bien sûr et aussi c'est aussi une
question de qui avec qui j'ai des
affinités et avec qui j'en ai moins
voilà c'est comme ça il y en a qui
peuvent demander des augmentations mais
qui n'en auront pas il y en a qui
qui n'en auront pas certaine
c'est tout simplement ça la nuance est
très très bénéfique elle est apportée à
pas grand chose qu'est ce qu'elle veut
alors moi je ne veux pas de votre argent
je veux juste de votre amour et comme
valérie je veux un rendez vous mais pas
sur ces 8 chez vous au
[Applaudissements]
daniel fade augmentation
jusqu'à bouffage de
cutanée l'honorer
c'est pas gagné on a
gagné c'est pas gagné du tout frais
payés vous allez voir nos contrées
[Rires]
mois de la déconne pour l'année
prochaine la déconne ans avec des live
si on peut faire revenir des lives
l'elite ça marche pas
j'aimais bien les a battus sera pas du
coeur je m'étais donné comme un début de
gestion et sinon parce que dans moi je
viens de loin avec des fois je fais des
siestes dans ma voiture j'aimerais bien
avoir une place de parking j'en ai marre
de me faire bien pourquoi c'est le graal
ici ya qu une place de parking qui en
place de parking qui de par vos
adversaires parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à moi j'habite ici mais cyril les
camarades habite proche d'ici donc ils
ont des taxes en tulle aura jamais mais
moi je vais j'habite on n'aura qu'à bien
je veux connaître 150 ont
rebondi en août bien d'accord ok 55
bornes jour donne beaucoup mon avis ça
va être compliqué ça c'est la morale ou
alors on est là sur une camionnette je
me mets entre la camionnette et le
trottoir et un parking chez vous puisque
vous n'habitez pas loin d'ici ah c'est
pas qu'on reste pas mal et il est
électrique de ma voiture chez vous et je
fais
c'est pour cela était avec plaisir sa
mémé mais malheureusement à et je suis
sur un projet de déménagement je me par
sur limoges
accord que ça passe encore bas loin
voilà donc que je veux former un show
vous mettre dans l'embarras je serais
quand même regrettable pourriez diminuer
votre parc de voitures au lieu d'avoir
douze voitures tu me voir ils en voiture
ici non ouais bon c'est un chien tu me
c'est la rumeur qui en vélo ouais en
vélo elle c'est un grand homme un grand
merci à tous et que kitty
et
en vélo est ce que tu as vu les deux
roustes et pas dérouter mes couilles
comme
moi non j'ai aucune exigence
particulière vous voilà c'est bon tiers
signé
un contrat comme cette année si vous
voulez bien de deux émissions par
semaine d'accord est en fait vous en
fait quatre mais voilà deux c'est déjà
très bien si jamais vous voulez plus et
basso sera plus et puis si vous voulez
de ce sera le salaire parfait le salaire
baisser à votre convenance un de toute
façon on n'a rien à décider je n'ai
rien demandé
quoi comme exigence éventuellement
des bruits une toile
pour elle je la loue rare et bien que
vous voulez quoi vous les deux je veux
bien être en phase de valérie bad est
vrai mais c'est possible non mais
l'année prochaine qu'on allait enfin si
le plan table ne change pas trop dur à
midi aura une résolution non n'y aura
pas de révolution par contre il ya des
têtes qui vont trouver alors quand vous
dites ça quand on parle de moi
à la barre vous si j'avais dit il ya du
riz et des boulettes
ça n'a rien à voir d'accord et surtout
continue exactement comme ça dans la
liberté ton d'expression avec douceur et
bienveillant de vos camarades tabou 20e
mois tout me va ouais ouais après jean
les deux côtés sa main bah oui ça va
très bientôt en valais de me balancer
deux styles différents et jean van
hamme est créé dans le cul refus
remaniera mais qu'il arrive en 4e bras
et lui l'an 2015
oui dix ans que j'entends alors déjà
céline merci d'exister
pendant ce temps la vraie priorité au
dialogue 1
ce qui se passe
les chéris je vais avoir une très très
très très grande nouvelle sachez que je
viens d'avoir le directeur financier d'
h2o la boîte de production a coproduit
tpm puis ma place de parc et sachets qui
peut y avoir une augmentation
mais il est chroniqueur à l'année
prochaine elle sera peu à peu un pompier
c'est vrai j'ai les yeux qui brûlent
face à tant de charisme
donc moi je fais pas cette émission pour
l'argent je le fais pour vous côtoyer au
quotidien ce que je veux mon rêve en
fait c'est de passer plus de temps avec
vous dans votre loge pour peut-être trop
nif les mauves est un peu plus
mes vestes robes et vestes oui mauvaise
et ensuite peut-être avoir ma propre
émission mais ma priorité numéro un
c'est de vous sucer vraiment
m
[Applaudissements]
il pleure il pleure je suis ému pleurs
du coup entre l'augmentation des
importations voilà je suis extrêmement
fière et sachez que guillaume genton
sera produit par ma personne sur un
autre projet
vraiment votre préféré après juin un
projet où il sera numéro 1 aulas sachez
le on peut pas en dire plus dans saurai
plus prochainement blast avoir plein de
nouveaux comme quoi sucéenne toujours
[Applaudissements]